-I am here with the NASCAR
championship four --
Joey Logano, Kyle Busch,
Martin Truex Jr.,
and Kevin Harvick right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are
the best of the best
when it comes to auto racing,
but I want to see how impressive
you are on a smaller scale.
I'm talking about
remote-control cars.
And we've -- we've designed
a pretty crazy obstacle course.
We want to see
how well you can handle it.
It's time for the
"Tonight Show" RC Pro-Am.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Tonight Show RC Pro-Am ♪♪
-All right.
Here's what's gonna happen.
First, we're gonna head down
this ramp right here, okay?
We're gonna complete three laps,
around the mini
Rockefeller Center ice rink.
Be careful --
it's very slippery.
And then we're gonna
have to weave through
three orange traffic cones,
pass by a beautiful
New York Cityscape,
over a rocky road,
through #SwingingLegs,
under the tunnel,
and then the first person
to launch themselves over
the final ramp is the champion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, get your remotes.
Get ready.
-Oh, boy.
-Are you good at this?
-Have you ever done this before?
-I am not -- No.
I played the game "RC Pro-Am."
Do you remember that?
-I loved that thing, man.
That was awesome.
-Awesome game.
Joey doesn't.
-I've never even heard of it.
-Oh, my gosh.
You're such a baby, yeah.
-Have you heard of Nintendo?
-I've heard of that, yeah.
-Perfect.
I got to catch you up.
You're gonna love it.
All right, wait.
Let me see if I can do this.
Are you guys good at this?
Oh, he's cheating already.
-Making sure it works.
Joey, oh, my gosh.
Here we go.
All right, Higgins?
-Everybody ready?
-Yes.
-On your mark, get set, go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my gosh!
Come on, help me!
♪♪♪♪
-That's it.
Two laps is enough.
-That one's in third.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stop! What are doing?!
Oh, my gosh!
[ Bell dinging ]
For the win!
-Bring it back.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You're off-roading.
You're off-roading!
-How did you get
out of the circle, man?
-I don't know, I don't know.
Put it back in!
Let's go!
-Go!
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-How did it go in
and come back out?
-Just throw it.
Higgins, just throw it over!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right, ready?
-Let's do it!
-Oohh!
[ Laughing ]
-Oh, my gosh,
just took it out right there.
That was major.
My thanks to Joey Logano,
Kyle Busch, Martin Truex Jr.,
the champion!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations, Martin.
And Kevin Harvick!